so this is your brain say hi okay it's a
representation of your brain brains
don't have hands
they have lobes and other structures
which we'll get to but I want to talk to
you about your brain you see your brain
is capable of incredible things but I
think a lot of times we can feel pretty
down on our brains on old inky pinky
here we beat up on them say bad things
about our brains abilities you know say
we have trouble understanding a subject
in school or solving problems or
learning a new skill it's easy to say oh
I'm not smart I'll always be this way
hey stop doing that what we think of as
intelligence what we think of as
smartness is not fixed is not stuck in
one place it's not permanent your brain
can improve your brain can grow come
with me on a journey of discovery here
we go into the brain scuse me coming in
hot this is a thing call the neuron oh
hey welcome to the inside of your brain
a neuron is a brain cell there's over a
hundred billion of these things making
up your brain put it this way there are
over 13 times more neurons in your skull
than there are human beings on earth a
lot of them they're the cells that help
you think mind you a single neuron and
let's call her Nellie
hi Nellie the neuron Nellie on her own
can't do all the thinking your brain
needs to even pick up a glass of water
fortunately she's got friends there's
dendrite Dave there's Alonzo the axon
there's Magnum myelin and look little
Sally synapse so teensy tiny your brain
behaves like a muscle if you're serious
about lifting weights right and you keep
it up on a regular basis for a long
period of time weeks months years you're
gonna develop muscles but you don't grow
muscles by doing nothing it takes effort
it takes struggle repeated failures in
fact you mess up and then you learn and
then eventually you manage to jump the
log or whatever problem you're trying to
solve wait we've lost focus you're back
to neurons when you struggle your
neurons are struggling to and that's
important because
when neurons struggle they lean on each
other they make connections they start
to form this densely connected network
inside your brain allowing little jolts
of electricity to pass down them more
and more efficiently that's thinking
faster that's your brain getting smarter
that's your brain muscle getting swole
kid so the next time you say to yourself
I can't do this I'm just too dense
remember that brain density is your
friend in fact the denser you are the
more connections between Nellie and her
neuron pals that you've got inside your
brain the stronger and more powerful
you're thinking parts become the more
you work through your frustrations with
the right learning strategies the more
your neurons get more used to working
together the closer you are to being
that much smarter now get out there and
do your best don't give up grow those
brains and remember you can learn
anything